hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome to
part four of my game of Thrones Season 4
preview today we're going to be talking
about Danny so beware of dragons as
always consider this a mild spoiler
warning four seasons 1 through 3 and
everything in books 1 through 3 up to
where we are in season 3 so you just won
the lottery and yung Chi only instead of
Bravo see gold you want every man woman
and child what do you do next do you
press your luck and head to marine or do
you make a break for Westeros but wait
turns out you can't make it to Westeros
without ships that's right the Narrow
Sea is in between you and your goal
meaning that Danny is going to have to
find a way to get to Westeros with her
army even though the end of season 3
Danny's kind of left hanging in the arms
of that giant mosh pit you kind of get
the idea that she's going to have to go
somewhere else obviously without
spoiling the books too much that place
that she's going to go next is going to
have to have some ships one of the
really cool things that happened to
Danny over the course of season 3 was
that she basically reassembled her
khalasar that's basically like a moving
city you have your warriors and you have
your citizens that's right remember in
season one when she married Khal Drogo
she basically got that entire khalasar
but after that first season they
basically fled after the death of Khal
Drogo so it's time to march on Westeros
but is she mentally ready to wage that
war against the Seven Kingdoms if you
remember I said that she basically needs
ship she can't get to Westeros no matter
how big our army is you can't put that
many people on the back of a dragon but
she's in luck all those cities up and
down the coast like Braavos have ships
so obviously she's going to be going to
one of those cities what ends up
happening when she gets there though
it's kind of up for grabs there's
certain events over the courses of books
3 4 and 5 to kind of leave her
stationary but we'll see what the
showrunners end up condensing I'm
betting that they're really going to
just be omitting a lot of secondary
storylines and characters and combining
a lot of the bigger conflicts that she
goes through but let me know what you
think what is Danny going to be doing in
season four is she going to be learning
more about becoming a queen is she going
to march on Westeros will she get her
ships just based on the pace of the show
and the time that each character gets I
don't think that we're going to have
enough time for Danny to do too many
things so obviously she's really
probably going to be spending most of
her time just learning about being a
queen for all these new citizens that
she's gained really important first
line though there was a notable recast
Michelle who spoon was basically recast
as dario taking over for ed skrein
that's mostly because of a scheduling
conflict i think but if you're really
big fan of the Dario character I think
that role is going to be expanded so
he'll get a lot more scenes in season 4
so get excited for that it was also
confirmed recently the actor Mark Gatiss
was playing the role of Tycho's from the
iron bank of Braavos and even though
that's a Bravo see character his
character is actually going to be in
King's Landing so I'll do a separate
video for him as always be sure to let
me know in the comments which characters
do you want to talk about next a laden
to my list my next game of Thrones video
this week would be for a little finger
be sure to subscribe to get it the
character has a lot of storylines that
they don't necessarily explain the show
so I'll try to keep it relatively
spoiler free because there are some big
revelations that happen to him in the
fourth book and I think they're going to
include those things in season 4 so be
prepared to have your mind blown because
Littlefinger is actually critical to
some of the bigger story lines from
season 1 that video will post on
Wednesday in the meantime you can click
here to watch all my other season for
previews and you can click here to learn
all about the working title for Star
Wars Episode 7 thank you so much for
watching high fives
you